outside the snow is piling up like seeds
dandruff on a cheap cotton poly blazer
but I didn't feel no cold on account of
I got a raging conflagration of hatred
in the pit of my tummy you see I can't
stand filmmakers who adapt comic books
like their Archbishop's interpreting
papal decree when it comes to straying
from the Holy Writ of graphic novels
these obsequious Fink's are more coward
than an Oshkosh dairy farm gee willikers
I'd like to squirt a slug through the
brainpan of each and every one of them
kapowee I have concerns about the new
Sin City scene and it's not just about
the overuse of color highlights I'm
worried that it'll be too faithful for
its own good when the original Sin City
it seemed like a refreshing alternative
to flicks like Judge Dredd daredevil
League of Extraordinary Gentlemen I'm
waiting to be impressed movies that were
simultaneously very lousy and completely
clueless about what it was it was so
awesome
about their comic-book source material
Robert Rodriguez broke away from that
hewing closely to the look and feel of
the monochromatic earned war by Frank
Miller even letting Frank Miller himself
direct some scenes but they're staying
close to the source material and then
their seating directorial Authority
altogether in the wake of Sin City some
filmmakers have gone full-on
fundamentalist treating each panel like
the inerrant Word of God and by some
filmmakers
I mean Zack Snyder his unwavering
devotion to Frank Miller's 300 yielded
some arresting images but it frequently
shaded over into cartoony absurdity and
Snyder's slavish Watchmen kept
everything from Alan Moore's graphic
novel except for the giant psionic space
squid it would have been twice as good
if it jettisoned twice as much
mechs are fundamentally a different
medium than movies movies or show don't
tell
but in comics the most interesting stuff
happens between the panel's and your
mind fills it in not to get off Scott
McCloud on you if the filmmakers refused
to fill that stuff in themselves the
results are a mess
take this literalness to its logical
conclusion and you get something like
Warren Beatty 'he's awful Vick Tracy
lots of primary colors just like the
comic lots of paper-thin
2-dimensional characters just like the
comic haphazard meandering plotting just
like the comic or even worse you've hit
something like the 1960s Marvel cartoon
show which was literally just panels
from the comics with a little bit of
animation well it must be the best
adaptation for it is the most faithful
one right right
Odin reluctantly agrees fright Miller's
Dark Knight Returns in Batman year one
are the greatest superhero comics ever
but Chris Nolan's Dark Knight was one of
the greatest superhero films precisely
because it took a Batarang to the bat
paradigm ditto with blade and ditto with
Raimi spider-man 2 so I hope that sin
city a dame to kill for maintains the
spirit of Frank Miller's comic while
creating something novel speaking of
spirit did you see Frank Miller's movie
adaptation of the spirit
the GAD and the Sin City sequel has
original new material by Miller is that
really a good idea and someone who read
its recent works like Holy Terror and
all-star Batman and Robin I say nay
what graphic novel do you think
Hollywood will ruin next I'm betting on
either ex machina or Y the last man let
me know your picks in the comments and
subscribe to the wire channel on YouTube